Ryan reyolds required over 2 million
customers for mmobile with paid ads and
I'm going to break down the best paid
ads that he's run and how you can model
the structure for whatever it is that
you sell in your marketing I'm Alex rosi
I'm the founder of ais.com we spend
millions of dollars every month on ads
we make tons of money and no one cares
let's start with the first ad at
mintmobile we like to do the opposite of
what big Wireless does they charge you a
lot we charge you a little they put
their names on Arenas we put ours on my
lower back so naturally when they
announced they'd be raising their prices
due to inflation we decided to deflate
our prices due to not hating you and if
this were one of their ads they'd end it
here with a happy customer so we'll end
outs with an angry
goat look at the angry goat okay so
let's break this down frame by frame now
notice though that this is a 30-second
ad let's start with the beginning of the
ad at M mobile we like to do the
opposite of what big Wireless does pause
so right here the hook is is basically a
contrarian hook so there's a little bit
of curiosity here because you're like
okay well one you recognize Ryan
Reynolds right off the bat and he's got
brand placement behind him so he's
making the association between him the
thing you like and the thing you might
not know which is mintmobile and so
that's a 101 strategy and there's a
reason that I wear this hat and why
underneath of my shirt which normally is
unbuttoned for those of you who are you
wild fellows the reason I I I I rep my
brand is to make that same Association
if there stuff that you use for my
content and it makes you money then
hopefully you associate that value with
me and acquisition. all right all right
so here this is a contrarian hook and uh
the curiosity is okay well what's
opposite about this thing versus what I
my current carrier all right let's hit
it they charge you a lot we charge you a
little okay pause so this is a clear
setup for an Us Versus Them strategy all
right and so this strategy is best
employed when you are not the market
leader all right so obviously mmobile is
kind of the underdog they're going the
small guy they're trying to face Goliath
obviously they're not even close to as
big as Verizon and AT&T so uh this
strategy makes sense if you're number
one you don't want to do US versus them
if anything if you want to use an Us
Versus Them structure you would use US
versus the alternative so rather than
another brand or other companies you
would be like us versus your couch right
if you were like the top fitness brand
or something like that they put their
names on Arenas we put ours on my lower
back so pause so here obviously he's
weaving in humor because that's part of
his personal brand and so he's basically
weaving in kind of like his brand sub
bullets as he's going through now every
ad has has three parts to it right
you're going to have the hook which we
covered right at the beginning there's
the meat of the ad which is typically
going to be the value and then uh at the
end of the ad uh there's usually going
to be either some sort of call action or
a payoff but let's keep going so
naturally when they announced they'd be
raising their prices due to inflation we
decided to deflate our prices due to not
hating you all right so here the value
is so think about when you're thinking
about value Creation in an ad um there's
at the most basic level more good stuff
less bad stuff all right and so when
you're you're writing your ads or you're
writing your copy and you're scripting
them out I think first from those two
buckets and so if we pull out our handy
dandy textbook for advertising and you
go to 134 so this is the leads book so
there's the steps for running paid ads
so first uh you have to know where to
advertise he's advertising everywhere
because everyone already knows who he is
and everyone already has a cell phone
and so his Market is everyone right now
that Parts straightforward the second
part is like okay how do I get the right
people to see it that's via targeting so
I'm sure there's different audiences
that look that do better and it might be
for Discount providers rather than
people who are maybe at premium they
might have found for example that uh you
know switching someone from Verizon
might be more difficult than switching
someone from like maybe uh pay on the
pay as you go type phone especially
given the price points now the third
part which is right here step three what
should my ad say and so this mirrors
that three-step process you got your
call out which is the hook you got the
value which is the meat and then you got
the call to action which is the end
besides the kind of General uh uh points
that I start that are more common hooks
obviously there's not exhaustive you can
have unlimited types of hooks that could
fit in a book but in terms of uh
Concepts he's using contrast here
contrast in two ways one is that there's
contrast visually like this is a bright
color this is something that's going to
pop out but then also he's using
contrast US versus them that's kind of
the theme here all right now from a
value perspective we get into the
interest step all right and so the
interest step is the best ads make
benefits look as big as possible and the
costs look as small as possible and so
from the benefits and cost perspective
what we're basically doing is a reverse
value equation and so the good stuff is
what's the outcome they want which
should be phone coverage right you
people would want it fast they would
want it easy and they would want it to
be likely okay now the negative side is
going to be what is a nightmare scenario
the worst case scenario um slow hard and
risky and so as he's describing the
benefit here which is less bad stuff the
nightmare scenario is that you pay a lot
right and you get basically the same
thing and if this were one of their ads
they'd end it here with a happy customer
and pause and so before this he said and
we do this due to not hating you right
and so again he's he's talking about the
knights mercen they charge you more and
they don't like you and so he's saying
we charge you less and we do like you by
implication and then he adds in more
humor so let's see it so we'll end our
with an angry
C look at the angry goat pause so
obviously puts a little bit more humor
in and to be clear he doesn't actually
show an angry customer he shows a sheep
right and so it wasn't actually like
showing a negative R which other
companies like
liquid death which is a water company
which took the you know took the took
the market by storm with cans of water
that looked like beer um they actually
had ads that were one-star reviews of
their product because they kind of went
again contrast that contrarian Angle now
here we finish with what the CTA right
so they make the offer and they tell
people mintmobile.com and what do I get
unlimited now speed just relative to the
cost low done fundamentally sound ad um
and obviously brought lots and lots and
lots of customers in so if we're
thinking about this ad in three slices
right we've got our hook we've got our
meat or value and we've got our CTA all
right and so we covered the hook we
covered the CTA let's talk about the
meat and so here we've got more good
stuff or less bad stuff now on the uh
good stuff what we're what we're
thinking through here is how can we make
it faster so we want describe speed if
we can how can we make it
easier and how can make it
risk-free now if we wanted to improve
this offer it would be month-to month
not just monthly right now there's some
disclosures at the bottom what does it
say there limited time only offer Now
new activation and upfront payment for
three months there we go uh promotion
rate for the first three months only
again so now we get to understand oh
it's only $15 a month for three months
and then it will go to who knows maybe
it goes to 30 we'll find out taxes and
fees are extra so there is more on top
of that and what are these fees that
they haven't disclosed and unlimited
customers using 35 gbt per month will
experience lower speeds okay so they do
slow you down and video streams at 480p
seful terms at mobile.com all right and
so that is the fine print on this but
big picture though if we wanted to make
this more compelling we would actually
flip those things we would say okay well
your dream outcome is to have
unlimited fast right internet and you're
not going to worry about getting
overcharged or getting your rates turned
down in terms of the speed that you're
getting downloaded that would make this
offer significantly more compelling
right now the thing that a lot of people
don't do in their advertising is is they
don't cover what I call the don't right
which is like what's the negative side
all right so here less negative um is
the uh what are all the things that suck
so paying money sucks um which would be
and the opposite this is slow uh
hard and risky right now in this ad
obviously they don't really have that
offer uh because a lot of the things
they have are they will they will slow
you down um they probably made signing
up easy they might not make canceling
easy um and then the risk is that
obviously you don't get what you want
now on top of this this is the real
don't this is the 2011 version of ads is
that we say okay well plus minus so more
bad stuff and less good stuff right that
happens in your life These are still the
same categories but when we when we sell
against the don't we say well you could
also not do this and instead you say you
will have more delays by not buying
mintmobile uh it'll be harder for you to
use your phone stuff and uh it will be
riskier for you to do it that's uh more
bad stuff and also you'll experience
less good stuff right and so each of
these so you can think about these as
mirror images of both sides if you do it
with us then you're going to have uh
less slowness less hardness less risk
which means that it's risk-free it's
easy and it's fast these just give you
different ways of more or less saying
the same thing and on the alternative
side when we're marketing against
someone or some or some idea or some
competitor then we're saying basically
the converse of that so let's let's
break down the next ad Wireless for 20
bucks a month pause so what's
interesting about this is they began not
really with a hook but they began with
the offer and so me right off the bat
I'm not like oh now I'm paying attention
I would be like all right there's an
offer here fine all right continue
that's not right pause so the good part
that they have here is I do think that
they have a reaction which I think is
overall like a good thing um I wonder if
I were to split test this I would
probably Lop off the offer and start at
the reaction and then and then flip the
order so that then you see the uh the
offer just so that there's something
interesting there now here they have a
mascot which shows up in the next frame
I think what the intention here was to
take Ryan reynolds's face away from
stuff uh and transition it more to a
mascot but my guess here is that his
Goodwill and his positive brand is
probably what drives a great deal of the
advertising return above par uh because
many people might not know mmobile if it
weren't for Ryan Reynolds they might not
even know that this is the same company
as his all right keep going I choose
chunky style milk because it has the
wholesome chunks growing kids need pause
so right here they're actually doing um
is a pretty clever advertising tactic
whether or not it was effective is you
know predetermined by the fact that they
didn't have as many sales as they wanted
so I'm giving you a little bit of a
foreshadowing here but what they did is
they actually just drew an analogy
between their service sorry other
people's Service uh and chunky milk so
this is another contrast style ad
they're saying we are a Ferrari they are
a clunker right they are a vesa or
whatever some small scooter something
that's a a huge contrast that basically
paints an analogy in someone's head to
say we are good they are bad and we keep
going the way that branding works is
that you don't actually brand in the
negative I can't say hey don't think
about pink elephants and me well of
course you're going to think about pink
elephants and now I forever am
Associated for those of you who see this
with a pink elephant and I will just cry
myself to sleep every night because of
it but the point here is is that they
said we don't want think we want chunky
milk and we started the the the video
starts with the actual uh brand itself
and then subsequently follows with
chunky milk and almost the entire ad is
talking about chunky milk and that it's
disgusting right and so people now just
simply associate mmobile disgusting
thing all right let's keep going unlike
smooth style
milk hey guys safe some chunks for me
pause so now they complete the loop and
say that's not right kind of like your
wireless Bell which is a a simile if you
want to use kind of like sort of is
basically drawing an equivalent between
two things which by the way is one of
the key ways of educating and
advertising with that we still have this
character that no one really knows uh
which is this random minty Fox uh but he
now I think did he have glasses in the
begin I don't know anyway let's keep
going oh that's not right all right stop
so they hit the three here right it's
easy it's online which to me would be
it's fast like it's not something that
you have to talk to anybody so that's
taking away some of the the pain
associated now they don't really hit
risk-free but I guess they kind of lower
the risk again with the small price here
um and you have clear call to action
which is the end of the ad let's hit it
right now buy one month and get two
months free at mintmobile.com right and
so they have their offer and then
obviously the call to action is just
simply go to the website all right so I
think the the mistakes in the ad are
that they B they that branding Works
whether you like it or not associations
occur and so they branded themselves
with chunky milk and they took out their
biggest uh star which was Ryan Reynolds
and so
unsurprisingly uh the ad didn't perform
as well all right let's go to a good one
hey it's Ryan Reynolds owner of mint
mobile pause all right so what we're
what he's doing here is he's because
what we have to think about when you're
advertising here because I don't
actually think this is an effective Hook
from a hook perspective but because this
is fundamentally not going to strangers
this is going to people who already know
who Ryan Reynolds is and so the
equivalent to that would be if I'm in a
local area and I run an ad and I say hey
Talon locals which is a sub you know sub
suburb in in Baltimore which is where
I'm from then people are going to be
like oh this is for me I recognize
something one of the four elements of of
getting influence with someone is
likeness or relatability you're like oh
I I know this guy all right so let's do
the next one it's the holidays and the
big wireless companies are busy spending
billions on Advertising all right pause
so yet again he continues to hit on this
US versus them uh concept and obviously
it's working so when you do have
something that works keep keep doing it
um and so he's drawing this parallel
between us and them yet again all right
keep going at mint we're not into
wasting money so we bought this spiffy
stock footage for $500 all right pause
so he he delivers One Core brand message
here which is that we're not into
wasting money now they're a budget
option and so it makes sense for this
that this ad did significantly better
one they have their their main person
two he's the focal point three the
scripting itself it's like oh you know
who I am and I'm not like these guys my
value is cheapness and so we made this
ad cheaply because we value money that's
kind of like I would say the implication
of the ad all right let's keep going our
footage also came with another hand so
we can let you know so he obviously
weeps in humor to then transition to the
offer and so these ads are super short
ads but when you have an ad that's this
short and it's going to audiences who
know who you are you pretty much just
make an offer and so from an advertising
perspective Eugene Schwarz has something
called the levels of awareness and so
the levels of awareness kind of are like
this reverse pyramid all right and so
you have unaware at the top and this is
about the problem so unaware you have a
problem aware so they know that they
have the a problem you have solution
aware you have product
aware and then you have most aware when
you make your hooks for ads you actually
make your hooks depending on what part
of this funnel you're actually finding
people and so the colder the traffic the
the the more different the ad will be
now when you have it unaware ad if
you've ever seen something that's like
Texas homeowners are getting uh
reimbursement checks for up to X XYZ in
this area or something that's going to
drive curiosity and so curiosity is
usually the very top of funnel for
people who have no idea what this thing
could be about and so it has nothing to
do with what the with the solution if
you've seen like five weird foods that
that help you lose stomach fat it
doesn't say whether they're going to
sell you a detox tea they're going to
sell you a zic they're going to sell you
a gym membership it starts all the way
at the top with curiosity now here's the
massive advantage that branded ads
people who are already recognized this
is what the rock this is what Ryan
Reynolds has Etc now every business can
do this every influencer business you
see who has 50,000 followers and then
begins to run ads for example you still
use the same exact strategy that Ryan
Reynolds is doing the thing is is just
that his warm audience is like everyone
whereas your warm audience might be like
a milon people and so what he's running
actually is an ad that's targeted at
most aware and so when you're targeting
most aware consumers you actually just
make an offer that's it and so that's
fundamentally what this ad does he just
draws a contrast and says by the way
we're cheap and you can buy 3 months
free and get 3 months free that's it
that's the whole ad so in my next book
that is coming out I talk about this
particular offer structure which is a
buy X get y right and so he's got a a
parallel structure buy three get three
um I would say that I found that buy one
get two or buy three get six if you can
contrast that you get more free than you
pay for it will typically convert better
than a mirror structure so I would test
buy one get two versus three and three
because you would probably uh end up
getting you would save money as a
business and you might end up still
converting more because the discrepancy
between what people pay and what they
get is higher if you switch to Mint
you'll get 3 months free on all of our
plans even unlimited feels like that
deserves an exclam Point whoa
easy
easy so he's just explaining the offer
here and I I mean if I wrote this ad I'd
probably have the CTA um this is yet
another joke that he weaves in you could
say that this is on brand for him so
what's one of the nice things I think
Ryan Reynolds does for his own personal
brand is that he does weave in direct
response advertising which is what this
is with what some people might consider
branding and so he does very much kind
of brand himself in these ads because
the ads are funny and he kind of like if
you literally look at this ad it pretty
much alternates humor moves the ad
forward humor moves the ad forward humor
moves the ad forward and it's a pretty
simple structure in terms of how he's
making this and so what we're doing here
as we're looking through this in terms
of tools is that one obviously he's a
he's a celebrity so we just looked at
his YouTube video and and ranked the the
the videos that have the highest views
but I can guarantee you virtually that
the ads that are are doing the best are
the ones that are being pushed out every
single day on meta on YouTube Etc from
ads not organic like sure he might get
some signups from the 6 and half million
views but believe it or not 6 half
million views for an ad not that much
right now we're pulling up the Facebook
ads campaign so if you don't know how to
do this by the way you just go faceb
just Google Facebook ads library and
then you sort and then you type in the
the account that you're looking at and
it's because Facebook is trying to be
transparent they show you every ad that
is running for an account and sometimes
also ads that are running in the past
now the rule of thumb here in terms of
looking for ads because you're like well
how do I know which one's working well
the easy way to do it is just say which
one of these ads has been running for a
long time and so the longer the ad's
been running the more likely that that
ad has worked well and so let's say you
put out 100 pieces of creative anything
that's new will always do better than
something that's old but if something is
old for a while then it means even
though it's old it's still performing
really really well so here are some of
the oldest ads that they're running so
let's let's pull it
up wow this is
boring okay um despite the fact that uh
I think this ad fundamentally from a
creative perspective kind of sucks uh
it's been running for 5 years or six
years so it's probably doing okay now I
will bet that this is a retargeting
campaign and so this is probably
converting very well for people who have
already seen some of the top of funnel
ads and so um basically if you think
about this levels of awareness that I
was just talking about retargeting ads
are always going to be targeting people
who are bottom of the funnel here which
is why it makes sense to retarget Simply
with the offer uh so it's like hey you
saw one or two ads or three ads because
we don't know what the
audience selection for this ad is but I
would make a guess that retargeting ads
because um the audience that enters into
the retargeting bucket basically the new
people that see the new ads uh and watch
past a certain point or click to the
site are a much smaller subset and
change frequently you actually keep the
creative the same because the bucket of
eyeballs changes whereas when you're
hitting a mass Market on a regular basis
everyone's seeing the ad so you actually
have to have far more creative top of
funnel than you do bottom of funnel so
if we just look at this this is an offer
recap essentially so it starts with the
price tells you what the what the dream
outcome is if we're looking at our
original framework we're reversing risk
right so we're just hitting through
these through the buckets of value uh
it's cheap it's fast and it's guaranteed
and this is a humor thing at the end
there um and then again they'll restate
the price all right so let's look uh
further up the funnel because I think
that'll be more fun and so it seems like
they have two very uh different
categories of ads which I think every
business should do and if you're not
doing this right now like do it I don't
know I'd like do it but look at look at
look at how Native these ads are right
these are clearly
iPhone these are clearly user generated
content so ugc um and they're just
displaying them as is so they they opted
for a more basic look and so some big
Brands would be like I don't want to
show this type of content cuz it Doesn't
reflect on my brand well um obviously
they're going for the scrappy Underdog
looking feel and the fact that they're a
budget provider kind of makes sense that
that they would use this Me by and large
I tend to lean towards using ugc because
it's like unlimited creative and you can
just test it really easily and I've
talked about how creating ugc Loops uh
with an abysses can just give you
endless ad creative but let's actually
watch this ad from beginning to end
here's my honest review of M Mobile's
and limited all right stop so honest
reviews if you look at search volume for
any business reviews is almost always
the second or third thing that comes up
and so this is obviously something that
people are going to want to know and so
it makes a really strong hook and then
the believability Factor here is I don't
see any disclaimers on this ad uh and so
it appears that this is not a paid actor
this is actually just somebody who's a
user who's giving a review and I'm going
to bet it's a good one let's go and
first off I don't have time to get my
main for my book all right so I mean
he's already framing whatever he's about
to say as he's actually edifying himself
believe it or not as you should trust my
opinion uh for what I'm about to tell
you because I am the type of person who
likes cheap stuff all right they call to
the boogo king second we're offering $15
a month for the first three months for
the new C
pause so they don't have disclaimers
around uh who he is but they do have
disclaimers around the offer itself
which you can see at the bottom there so
it's $45 up front all right so he said
$15 a month but when you actually uh go
to go to buy it it will probably be more
which you can see there all right I paid
$5 on I have't looked that there we go
so he did say he does include the
upfront fee okay that feels good I had
to pay my phone three months it's been
well so from an offer structure here he
begins with 15 and then he says he paid
$45 because he bought three months so
they so from from a from an advertising
perspective what they're doing is
pulling cash flow forward so they can
afford to acquire the customer and so if
you pull the three months forward then
they're going to give six months because
it's a buy free buy three get free he
said he's the BOGO King buy one get one
right so they buy three so 15 time three
that's 45 and then there's another three
months afterwards so likely he's not
going to get build for 6 months after
paying $45 which is fairly comp offer
all right the service the service hand
be great it's wonderful call me be me if
you want to reach me word again possible
so what is the biggest concern someone
has so there are these two pricing
scientists called van West or it's one
guy I think his last name is Van West
anyways and so there are uh kind of four
uh questions that you can ask when
you're trying to figure out what to
price something so the four questions
are number one what is a price that's so
high that you wouldn't even consider
buying it the second question is the
Other Extreme which is what is a price
that's so cheap you wouldn't believe
that it would work that it wouldn't
actually function and then the two
questions in between are what price is
just high enough that you'd consider
doing it you'd ultimately buy it but it
would it would hurt or it would sting or
it would be uh something you have to
think about before making the purchase
and then on the kind of like the from
the upside is like at what price do you
think this would just be a great deal
all right and so what they're hitting on
here is when the big fears that that a
budget consumer is going to have which
is okay it's $15 a month but am I going
to get service is anyone even going to
hear me like is am I always going to
have one bar at all times like that
would suck right and so he's hitting on
the biggest fear that a customer is
going to have so if you think about the
value part of the ad he's saying less
negative and more positive so you might
be wondering less negative no more
positive and so it's a very simple
structure and you can also stack
multiple of these in a row if you have a
longer ad that you're trying to run all
right let's hit the rest can made the
source of mobile save some money and
reinvest and so he actually makes the
CTA at the end which is brilliant I mean
that I mean it's very kind of him maybe
they ran an ad contest uh for people to
you know submit their ads maybe they
didn't and this guy just liked making
fun videos who knows maybe he's a great
Creator we have no idea um but by and
large though uh it's a fundamentally
sound ad this guy gave a good hook he
edified himself he said uh what he loved
about it he gave the price uh and then
he said what's your biggest fear it's
less bad stuff more good stuff great
benefits to you save some money invest
call to action straightforward ad all
right so now let's go back to Ryan R so
you'll notice though they have far more
ugc ads that are that are running and
that's because ugc you just get so much
more creative because it's it's it's
leveraged right you can use the entire
Community people all of your customers
which I think a meta concept here that
any business owner can take I I mean I
am a massive advocate of this is try and
build the advertising machine within the
business itself that way you don't
always have to generate 100% of your ads
you only have to generate 20% or 10% of
your ads on a regular basis and you let
your community of customers generate the
other 90 all right let's hit the next
Ryan Reynolds hey it's Ryan Reynolds and
this year our holiday commercial is just
S 5 pick up for $5 for a yard sale oh
good we're still doing this doing what
well the holiday offer all the wir
company stop doing errs in January so I
want to make sure that we don't stop
loving our customers just because
December's over is future me
micromanaging and am me just just got to
be offer it's zero commercial
now I am sufferable this is how you're
using time travel you irresponsible son
of a so let's break this down uh
frame by frame in terms of the ads so we
go to the beginning boom he introduces
himself hey it's and so I will bet that
they have found that when he introduces
himself uh that hook tends to work
because everybody kind of knows who he
is and so in some ways it's like it's
it's not a true direct response cold uh
Market open because no one who's really
watching this and buying is cold traffic
everyone kind of recognizes who Ryan
Reynolds is and so they just reinforce
that with all the brand trust that he
brings to it which is fundamentally why
he did the deal to do this to to to
invest in this business and help grow it
all right let's do it this year our
holiday commercialist just St I picked
up for $5 from a yard sale oh good
you're still doing this pause so the $5
from the yard sale he doesn't even show
any of it and it's just kind of this
like random add in um and so this ad is
primarily humor driven the Clone version
is something that many many companies
have used this angle and this is more of
a behavior science thing but seeing two
people who are ident pacle draws a lot
of attention like think about twins of
any kind I'm not going to get into
anything else there we'll just leave it
at that all right twins are inherently
more interesting like you look back and
forth you look back and forth and it's
attention grabbing any people now if
they wanted to make this even crazier
this is the the the behavior side um if
they actually had them acting in sync uh
it would draw even more attention just
from a from an advertising perspective
but obviously there's a little bit of
banter here all right let's do it what
well the holiday offer all be called we
stop doing errs in January so I wanted
to make sure that we don't stop loving
our customers so yet again they have
their winning theme which is US versus
them and they hate their customers and
we love our customers and so they are
continuing to run the ad also as a total
side note um if the ad converted which
I'm assuming it did uh they actually got
a lot more runtime on it because of the
excuse they're using for why they're
going to continue to run this
promotional offer now they've been more
or less running the same offer this
whole time and so inside of my offers
book I talk about this so the last
chapter in $100 million offers is the
magic headline formula and so once you
figure out what your offer is going to
be you then basically bundle it over and
over and over again and so same bundle
different rapper and so during the Super
Bowl I'm sure they'll call this their
Super Bowl promotion during the holidays
they'll call it the holiday promotion
during the Spring they'll call it their
Springtime promotion during the summer
they'll call it their sumtime summertime
and when it's fall they'll call it the
back to school promotion and so you
don't actually have to change the offer
once the offer is winning you just
change the wrapper around the offer to
make the offer feel new and different
when in reality it's still the highest
converting offer you've got and uh I I
talk about this a little bit more length
uh in this chapter but I like to think
about it as being like a fraternity
party planner so back in my fraternity
days uh you didn't really need to have a
reason to have a party because you're in
college and parties are what you do but
you would invent a reason why so it's
like John got his wisdom teeth pulled
ker right and so you would just think
about anything any reason why you can
imagine and at the end of the day
customers don't care what the reason is
they about the offer but the reason
itself creates novelty and I think if
you are a small business I think this is
one of the most underutilized
advertising angles is think about
ridiculous thing it's my dog's birthday
and because of that I giving two months
free to anybody who joins my gym
whatever right it like I turned 37 7
weeks ago and as a result I'm running a
sweek promotion like it doesn't matter
but the ma the thing that does matter is
the offer and they already tested that
so once you nail the offer you just go
endless variations and wrapping paper on
it so now let's look into this and
there's an interesting little tidbit
here that I think anyone can take so
they have a lot of ads from this
particular Creator so this may be an
influencer this may be somebody that
they paid we'll see if they disclose
that regardless you can see that there's
a lot of ads from this Creator so I'm
guessing that they did pretty well or
that they paid her a decent amount of
money to make a lot of ads now what I'm
curious about is whether they kept the
meat of the ad the same and just
alternated the hooks or if they actually
made entirely new ads so let's let's
let's check it out he say if your grown
up sign your own phone we your man
is lesson two of these opies per montho
all hands are $50 month three new
so Haron advantage and all right so this
is actually pretty good advertising um
and I I'm going to I'm going to break
down why so the Ryan Reynolds ads don't
follow traditional direct response
because they start with him just saying
who he is because it's not really direct
respon well it is direct response but
it's going to the most aware audience
but for many of us business owners
people don't know who we are and so we
have to start with something uh a little
bit different so people might not know
who she is and so we start with the call
out right which is people noticing your
ad is the most important part of the ad
by a lot if we're thinking about this we
need them to think oh this is for me
that is the thought that you want
someone to think or feel the moment they
begin the ad because then that means
that you have paid you've gotten them to
pay attention all right so if I am a
parent I might pay attention because I'd
be thinking about my kids and if I'm a
kid I might think about now if I'm sing
person I might just ignore this that all
together all right and
we're
is two ofice per month so this is why I
said I think this is good advertising so
if you're going to mass Market again
this is a this is drawing an analogy or
metaphor right and what's really clever
about this is that they're just
translating $15 into what the real cost
is for somebody on an everyday um
expense that most people just don't
really consider a real price or real
actual cost and so you'll see this in a
lot of different companies and I do
think it's really clever advertising um
because I think it makes the price real
for people and if you've noticed uh like
sometimes insurance plans would be like
for less than a dollar a day you can
insure your loved one and so you can say
it as the price so be like for her it's
15 so $15 a month they could say for
less than 50 cents a day um obviously
she just say two coffees a month but I
would imagine like you could probably
say for less than a pack of gum a week
right you could you could do a different
like that would be a hook that I would
think would probably work just as well
as the coffee I think coffee's been a
little bit overdone because a lot of
people do things in terms of coffee at
the same time maybe people do that
because it works so um I would probably
alternate if this is me being the
creative director I would alternate
different props here um that would
resonate potentially with different
audiences there now if we're going for
kids how many of them are buying
expensive coffee I don't know what
things are they buying that are in that
price range I would probably look at
that as some of the substitutes i' look
at for the analogies or metaphors that I
draw in uh to compare the price of My
Thing versus The Thing and here's the
key part that they're already spending
money on all pans are $50 B for the
first remas adue customers so St taking
advantage of your par
andage off so all we're doing all all
they're doing here is just restating the
offer so this is pretty straightforward
and then they put a little joke at the
end fine and so actually the last few
words it ends soon is drawing upon
urgency and so uh what's what's
interesting about this is from a
compliance perspective for advertising
um the promotion could end soon I'm not
sure
how uh compant it is to have a promotion
end soon and then the same offer Begin
Again the next month for a different
reason so I don't know if your holiday
promo ends on the first and then on the
second your spring promo starts but it's
the same offer uh that seems great to me
I personally don't care I think it's
fine but in terms of uh legal people uh
you can take it up with them um but the
the the part that's key here is that if
you can uh pull urgency which is one of
the elements of an amazing offer right
here page 112 um you want to say urgency
is by X date or X time and so now
they're saying and soon okay that's how
they do it so soon is subjective and so
soon soon could be for me 10 years from
now that is how they uh they were able
to have some little urgency around their
CTA and probably have a compliant I'm
glad we got through that together let's
look at the next ad here uh and the key
part that I want to look at is this is
the same Creator so I want to see if
they're doing similar hooks or they're
just doing entirely different ads all
together let's do it welcome to a
conversation between me and a big
Wireless sales you like to save money on
your phone bill in the New Year I'm
taking advantage of n Mobile's new
customer offer right now for their
unlimited plan you can 100% guarantee
that if you go with us you'll save huge
compar to your current plan how much you
hang right now with mobile oh $15 a
month they the largest IB Network in the
nation and I offer you a similar plan at
a much higher price just watching the
last ad and this one what is now clear
to me is that they're running viral
organic formats and so the first one
started with a PSA PSA grown to your own
fan all right and so psa's I'm guessing
um that format probably was a viral
organic format and if this is a Creator
which I'm assuming she is um I don't
know her name is but I'm assuming she's
a Creator I'm sure you guys can let me
know in the comments um she now has
another format that is a is a fairly
common uh viral organic format uh
somebody who's done a really good job of
this is Erica Colberg she does like
Financial stuff and she does a lot of
conversations or pseudo conversations
that happen between Representatives
company and her she does legal stuff but
like fundamentally exact same format and
so that's the format but if we're
looking at the theme guess what theme it
is yet again US versus them right and so
they have just found that from the
Underdog perspective that theme works
well why didn't no one tell me about
mmob yal I'm honestly shocked that this
isn't blowing up my be right now you can
get mmob United pay for $15 a month
three mon when as a new hust and I love
about it is it's reliable affordable
it's a news deal so it ends soon you
want to pay less three your phone plan
in 2025 don't wait in the mobile rather
deal while you still hand I'll right
here for you we basically just have a
hook and then a ton of urgency all right
now the thing is is that yet again she
says it ends soon now reason why it was
new year so that makes it a little bit
more believable or compelling but at the
end of the day they could run this New
Year's plan for like six months who
knows all right now the hook here is a
pretty common hook for like reviews and
things like that that happens in organic
um I will say that for those of you who
do consume organic shorts like this on a
regular basis you probably have seen
these and it almost this is me
personally just saying this this is a
pretty common structure for people who
get paid to do an endorsement and
they're like why has no one told me
about so and so's protein powder it
tastes so amazing I thought it was going
to be right and then they go into it
right um all right let's just go to the
next one because you'll notice there
actually let's let's just hit the number
of times she hits UR in this cuz I think
that's actually kind of interesting I'm
honestly shocked that this isn't R right
now you can get P for $15 a month for
the first three months when you sign up
as a new customer but I love about it is
it's reliable affordable hereo it's a
news deal so two also it ends want to
pay less for your phone plan in 2025
don't wait mobile rather
steal so she makes five urgency ctas in
in basically last 15 seconds of the ad
all right so um obviously this is direct
response being the goal to get someone
to respond immediately for the ad he is
agan not M the sale put the date in your
phone February that is when mob offer
for $15 a month for the first three
months of new customer in yes you could
go the rest of the winter only paying
$45 for a Pham pan without compromising
on quality the savings here are insane
commu to wireless so make sure
you so let's let's I think this one's
worth breaking down PSA do not miss the
so that's the hook right so again she
does the PSA thing and so the PSA is yet
again a viral format something to
consider if you are running ads is look
at what organic formats are
trending uh for creators and there are
formats believe me there are formats and
try and see if you can get your ads to
mimic that format because then it will
look more native uh and when you have
like fundamentally the best
advertisements are things that don't
look like advertisements and like if if
you this were think like this if this
were just a Creator who were making this
recommendation you'd be like wow it' be
incredibly compelling and so the more it
can look not like an ad uh then the
better in general it'll convert all
right so let's do the next thing I'll
put up this date in your phone February
is pause so they do actually have an end
to this promotion and so now this is
again a hard push on urgency but we've
looked at a bunch of ads all of them
have at the same price which is
$15 um and so that obviously is the
price point that they have seem convert
and having the three Monon offer is
what's working and an's offer of
unlimited data for $50 a month for the
first three months of new customer in
pause so same restatement of offer she's
just explaining what it is and if you
are making an offer you just want to do
it as as clearly as possible and you can
see the disclaimer in the middle of the
screen if you do have terms around
payments like for them obviously it's
they're paying it all upfront then that
comes and there's obviously rate
limiters in terms of how fast it is um
but she tries to attenuate that big
concern which obviously I'll bet you if
they are uh good advertis ERS which they
are they probably read the comments and
the number one concern by the way big
Pro tip here if you want to know the
things that you need to include in your
ads in terms of what concerns prospects
have not customers but prospects have is
actually just read the comments because
people will tell you their objections
for why they didn't sign up or why they
what they don't like about your thing
and then in your next batch of ads you
can include those key points and
overcome them all
right you could go the rest of the
winter only pain G pan without
compromising on quality pause so two
things here one is she just restates the
offer in a different way so instead of
$15 per month for three months she then
just translates it again saying that
means $45 until the end of the winter
all right so it's just a different way
of restating it which I think is worth
doing because sometimes it just hits
different for different audiences and
sometimes it's like oh that actually I
mean sometimes $15 a month for three
months for some audiences will convert
and for other audiences $15 or $45 until
the end of the winter might be even more
compelling I would say for me personally
I think that is actually more compelling
all right now the last part that you
said is without compromising on quality
now I think that in other ads they hit
harder on the fact that the quality
isn't compromised she just puts a little
oneliner in there because it's the
biggest concern anyone would have with a
budget provider the here are
insane big picture here um
they're running a pretty clear direct
response strategy um they're leveraging
ugc uh which every business can should
have if you have a brand spokesman then
introducing them obviously in this Ryden
Reynold scenario he continues to do it
so I'm guessing that it works um I would
be curious to test I haven't seen it I'd
be curious to test what
a cold or harder hook uh would do with
Ryan Reynolds as the person in the ad
like that would probably be one of the
first things I would test if I were
testing offers I would look at by one
get two or by two get four um and see
how that converted uh alternatively by
three and three is fine nothing wrong
with it but I would those are things
that I would test the hell out of um I'm
I'm assuming that sometimes you can
break it back from what number converts
so $45 may be the number and then it's
just like how many ways can we mix and
match uh $45 right what's that you guys
want to see where all of this traffic is
pushing fine we'll also look at the
landing page let's do it okay so this is
mobile.com which is their CTA uh in
every ad all right and I do think big
picture um if you have all your traffic
pushing to one page
um then you want to make sure that it's
all congruent and actually it's a huge
mistake I think a lot of marketers make
is that you have all these different
creative Hooks and stuff but then like
you don't actually go for congruence and
one of the easiest ways to drop
conversion is have someone click
somewhere and then not get what they
think they're getting and so a lot of
the elements here are look okay let's
just look at this page here all right so
right on the top time is literally
ticking so they're showing true urgency
um right at the top big banner um saying
like you need to act now now on top of
that they have a banner across the top
that is probably also something that
moves forward in the funnel and uh if
you look at acquisition. comom for
example we have a banner across the top
because it's actually one of the most
clicked buttons and so you can have the
same CTA with multiple buttons on the
page and in general rule of thumb not
forever but if you only have one CTA on
a site if you add another you will
increase conversions if you add a third
you'll also probably increase
conversions at a certain point you have
too many referees on the field and no no
one can see the actual offer but in the
beginning
two three sometimes ctas in terms of
button for someone to take action will
usually increase the conversion of the
page all right now we're hitting they're
basically just slamming you over the
head with urgency now they don't have
scarcity because it's unlimited
customers so that's not where they're
hitting they're just going on time here
so big picture for those you don't know
scarcity is uh uh limiting quantity
urgency is limiting time and so people
talk about scarcity and urgency
interchangeably and that's not how it
actually works all right there separate
things that can be combined but they
exist separately all right now they do
have a caveat it's new customers all
right so it's not all customers but new
customers get 3 months of unlimited
premium Wireless for $15 a month all
right so let's I mean it's pretty clear
what they want us to do here let's
scroll down let's go all the way down is
there anything else
there okay so two plant for the price of
one so if you switch from one of their
primary competitors uh they have a
separate offer for you there all right
now let's look at the secret
sauce I'll bet you this is optimized for
mobile too all right so 5G for free
we're online flexible payment plans okay
uh bring your own everything fine so
what's really interesting about that b
bye um another budget provider which you
may have heard of which is Spirit
Airlines uh has the same thing they call
it your ass and gas so they say like we
give you nothing and they kind of lean
into how cheap they are and they are the
cheapest provider but they do nickel and
dime people so let's scroll back up and
let's actually let's go like we're going
to convert so why would they have so
because this is this is this is actually
like Dev work that they'd have to put in
so there's probably a reason they added
this bar in I would imagine the number
one concern which they also talk about
in their ads is what's the service
quality right and so someone's like I'll
switch to it if there's really good
coverage in my area and so they're
probably resolving one of the biggest
concerns so let's just do acquisition.
comom zip so yep there we go all right
so there we go so they tell us that our
device is compatible and they have
excellent coverage now I'm going to be
real with you um my question would be is
like what's
excellent now they do have a map so they
can visualize it okay so they've got
some towers that looks like it's right
there at the corner but all right if I'm
trying to make a decision I might say
well they said it's excellent so I guess
I'm going to consider so now we go view
plans so let's do that okay so this was
actually leads us to the same place as
the original button so if someone takes
a detour and then goes there pretty it
basically you handle the objection and
then they go back to the sale all right
so choose your plan all right so let's
see what we got here we got 3 months 6
months 12 months they obviously want um
you know they're drawing attention to
the 3-month offer and so what's
interesting is that they have the same
starting fee but just different ongoing
fees after the fact to me the six-month
offer is a dummy
offer and I'll bet you they have their
their split between the three and the 12
and so like look at look at why they
would do this so it's like okay well I
can only commit to three months and then
it's $30 a month or I can pay $35 a
month uh with 210 up front I'm like I
don't know like for me if I look at this
I'm either 3 or 12 and so when you have
three tiers by the way you almost never
want the three tiers to be evenly split
so we're going a little bit into pricing
but YOLO we can do what we want it's our
video so so where you move the middle on
a three tier offer determines where you
want to nudge the customer okay so if I
want more people to take my uh 12mth
offer I will make my six-month offer
really close to the 12-month offer and
so I'm like oh well well shoot this is
so close I'll just I'll just do that one
right so this is the typical small
medium large soda play that movie
theaters has done for ages right so
let's say that you've got equal ounce
differences
between uh between sodas okay so let's
say that this is 10 ounces this is 15 oz
and this is 20 ounces okay so that's
what that's what these sodas are
obviously at a movie theater it' be like
a gazillion ounces and they just give
you a gallon of whatever soda you want
all right here here you're asking
someone to make a logical decision and
it's proportional to how much they buy
and they're not really saving anything
by buying more so functionally this
would incentivize people to go here
because there's no savings for buying
more and if you wanted to just get some
more later you take on less Risk by
buying a smaller purchase and you could
always just double up again later if you
so desired now what does this next
pricing tier tell you so let's say we
keep our $5 and then we have $6 here and
then we've got $10 here what does this
tell you that tells you here that this
is the best value option the first is
here now let's look at a different
pricing scheme so if we have $5 uh on
the low option but let's say that now
we've got $9 on this option and $10 what
is the pricing CH that we're pushing
towards we're like well dude for an
extra dollar I'm getting another 5
ounces this is not a bad gig now because
of this uh basically dichotomy between
the 10 and the 20 um we would probably
realistically what this would probably
be priced at like if we were in the
movie theaters this would probably be
eight bucks this would probably be seven
and so this would then push more people
to hear right and so how you pric your
three options you can tell what offer A
smart business owner is trying to
incentivize you to take so it depends so
we're getting into a little bit of
advanced pricing but you're an advanced
person so let's talk about it all right
so if I have this $6 option what does it
really communicate well you think like
for a dollar more I'm going to get 50%
more soda that's a pretty good deal for
here for a dollar more I get another 5
ounces of soda and so these prices are
always taken in in aggregate right now
if I have a lot of people coming in the
door and everyone's buying Smalls and I
want them to upgrade then I'm going to
put my price here if everyone's
cominging in and they're getting mediums
and I want to push them the larges then
I'm going to move my price of mediums up
to make the large more appealing so what
you're ultimately trying to do is
maximize Revenue per soda buyer right
and so it'll depend where your average
customer is actually entering the
business to determine which of these you
would actually push uh so this is a
sales page all right and so sales pages
are different than landing pages so the
first page was relatively short just
wanted to get people to take the next
step and they have probably tested
pushing people straight to the sales
page and it probably doesn't convert as
high so they have that intermediary step
to get more qualified uh people to the
page why does that work no idea I can
just tell you that often does work when
you have too much traffic going and not
enough conversion you add a step you add
friction and then it sorts the right
traffic all right so let's look at the
actual page structure here so let's go
to the top so boom big thing we have our
urgency yet again and then we have our
offer right there in bold so that
everyone doesn't miss the thing last
chance yet again 50% off cool okay
they're restating the offer multiple
times and then they restate the benefits
underneath highp speed so if you're
looking at this you've got headline
subhead and then three bullets which is
a really common structure that I talk
about um
and it's interesting because above the
fold which is when someone loads on
their phone you'll see a very common uh
structure in the paid ad section 147 I
talk about three different landing page
structures that work really well and so
what they have here is they're using
layout three above the top all right so
they've got headline subhead right so
unlimited premium is headline subhead is
last chance and then the three bullets
right here now they have I have mine
below below the button they have theirs
above minor difference but fundamentally
they're using this structure now notice
I have attention Avatar at the top what
do you think that is that's time is
literally ticking and it says new
customer offer so Avatar is right there
attention new customers all right like
these are Timeless advertising
principles because they work this is how
this is how you convert traffic all
right so we've got the button I one tiny
tweak I would consider on this page is I
think the button is not visible enough
and so I would consider making that more
uh I would make it jump out more uh
because I think you could easily miss
that all right so let's scroll down it
says choose your PL now it's telling you
what to do okay great so now um this is
just all plans include this are you new
great and then just restates the offer
yet again all right um and then we see
our our three six and 12 month plan now
they made it uh userfriendly for mobile
so that you can you know toggle between
them uh which I think really
interestingly so imagine the user
experience here so if I'm looking at
this I'm going see $15 a month and I go
to six six months up it goes up and then
I go to 12 months $15 a month huh what
is that telling me to do well I came for
the three but man this one for 12 isn't
bad and so what's interesting about this
is that the intro offer is is 15 a month
and then it bumps up right but the
12-month offer is 15 a month and then it
stays 15 a month and so if someone has a
sensitivity to that price point then
they basically make it available to them
it's like hey if you want to stay at 15
a month you can you just got to make the
commitment right all right so let's
let's scroll down a little more all
right did you know once three months are
up your new customer offer you can renew
yeah so they're saying hey if you can't
so this is a if you can't decide right
now don't worry you can change it later
which is a great re risk reversal all
right so facts so now they're getting
into features here and they're probably
going to show speed because what's the
biggest concern everyone has coverage
and speed all right so they're going
through these things and for us we
already checked our ZIP code beforehand
which they helped observe now I don't
think anyone's going to know anything
about this like like I honestly and
maybe this is a compliance thing that
they have to show which is very possible
um so that one I don't know it might be
a legal thing all right let's scroll
down cuz obviously this is not going to
convert anyone okay bring your family so
this is an upsell potential so it's like
okay not while I've got you cuz what's
another concern someone has well I don't
want to switch on my own I want to bring
my whole family over because I don't
want to be a separate plan than them
cool so they gave a family plan all
right now yet again we scroll down to
the
bottom and if you missed it because
let's say you think about click Journey
right so someone clicks over and they
didn't they just went straight to the
offer now that they're actually in
consideration so they're thinking am I
going to am I going to take this offer
am I going to take my credit card out
they might now this the coverage device
Checker is what I consider a buying
question and so sometimes on a sales
call this is obviously doing this in in
a virtual setting but there are
questions that are like there are
questions that are kind of more
open-ended like Discovery questions that
a that a customer would ask and if
someone says like talk to me about
payment plans right that's a buying
question they're strongly in
consideration and so this is something
to help overcome any obstacles around
purchasing so they were like okay the
price makes sense if you have it in my
area um I I'll attend your your gym how
far away are you from me right that's
going to be a real consider like and if
you're close enough they have some line
in their mind that if it's over it it's
acceptable and they'll make the they'll
make the purchase all right so scroll
down and this last section is super
common um on a sales page which is FAQs
all right so almost always having an FAQ
on a sales page will increase conversion
because just think about every one of
these questions as a couple percentage
points of customers that haven't gotten
all their questions resolved yet and
either want a deeper explanation for
some of the sentences or headlines from
above or they have some unresolved
concerns that didn't really make sense
to weave into the page because it would
overall lose some people and so you
basically stack those at the bottom and
you've probably seen this on a lot of
pages even if you look at like an Amazon
uh purchase page they're going to have
their FAQs at the bottom where the the
seller will answer some of the questions
that people are asking all right and so
if you by the way if you want a really
great way to study like how to make
sales Pages study Amazon think about
about how they structure their pages and
how many elements of persuasion are
woven in that are real and actual now
they obviously you know they're a
trillion dollar company and so they have
a lot of resources at their disposal but
you can still use the elements of
persuasion that they have right and
fundamentally that's what they're
harnessing here and at the very bottom I
see this as a um if you haven't decided
to buy yet why don't you enter our
long-term nurture sequence where we'll
send you emails to hopefully get you to
buy later right and so that's basically
what we're doing here so so so what's
that you you want to see the emails that
they send to convert more customers fine
we'll look into them okay so uh Big
Picture This is their actual email
sequence so we looked it up you'll
notice that these are very visual so
these are very um picture driven so I
want to make a clear Point
here it's I would say it's very split in
the types of products that are being
sold what types of emails convert and so
I've seen this is just me Alex's point
of view um
pictures do really well with physical
products and low ticket items uh so
people just like click and buy right if
you sell services or complex services or
complex products or high ticket products
often times basically almost the exact
opposite uh perspective this which is
lots of text um that's plain text maybe
one hyperlink that's all not formatted
to basically make it look like a real
email that someone might send to you
that tends to be the best deliverability
which will ultimately convert more
people for those more complex things so
if you sell services that are complex I
would lean towards that here if you're
e-commerce which fundamentally this is
e-commerce it's just a phone service
that you're getting um it makes sense
now one last Point here is that notice
that they don't offer phones remember
the booe so they're able to sell at a
much lower price point because most of
the other carriers include the phone in
some sort of payment plan with your
service and so a big portion of what
you're paying for is the th000
smartphone that you're you know sub that
they're subsid ing for you over X period
of months with a decent uh markup all
right so let's look at the offers they
have so email one is they just say they
just restate the offer cool let's go to
the next one all right uh now they say
it's easy so let's think about the
elements of value here right so first
they restate the offer then they say by
the way it's easy now the makings of
mitt mobile so now they're saying okay
someone didn't take the first two so now
let's just give them a little bit more
information right let's talk more about
the value that they're getting that's
the next email yeah and so here they're
also telling a little bit of the of the
of the story of the founder or or at
least the spokesperson and so this would
be more common if someone hasn't made
the purchase for you uh purchase with
you yet you're explaining more about
yourself basically trying to build some
trust build rapport with Prospect all
right let's go to the next
one all right so now they're hitting the
family people and they're like maybe you
didn't buy because of this reason you
might have missed it on the site and so
what they're really doing is they're
chunking down a lot and just focusing on
one obstacle at a time which is what I
would encourage you to do in email
followup is there's going to be let's
say 13 reasons people aren't going to
buy and instead of saying here's 13
Reasons let's handle them all you just
hit one email at a time that hits each
reason in order of prevalence meaning
the more common the concern is the
earlier on in the email sequence it
should be all
right now uh here's the 411 on Sim so
this is like this is going to be a
concerned question this is a detailed
question where someone's like we do what
about uh SIM cards what what about my
use case I'm a special snowflake so
they're covering the special snowflake
scenarios um in this and I would imagine
they continue down this process now if I
had to rate this email followup um I
would probably rate it like I'm being
real probably a five out of 10 um main
reason here is uh you know they're just
hitting basic they're just restating the
offer and over and over again um I think
that what could make this better is if
they made it feel a little bit more
tailored right and so if they could
expand in personalization now I don't
know what segmentation they have in the
background but personalization their
marketing and um thinking about
onboarding a customer before they're a
customer um is a great way to take
people get get people to do those first
steps like that coverage question that
they have it's like can I get someone to
take a micr step towards me right and so
I'd be thinking what other things are
kind of micr steps that get someone who
who Who's going to get further along the
the road of consideration before they
make a purchase another one would be
like okay can we give can we deliver
them some sort of lead magnet so once we
have their zip it's it's like here's
other people in your area who have said
that this is really good that would
probably be really compelling another
type of testimony I might might read um
someone who's like you another one might
be someone who considered buying at the
same time as you and is now already
enjoying the benefits right and so
people thinking cohorts so it's like if
I considered buying this last week and
it shows someone else who did buy last
week and is enjoying the benefits it
becomes more compelling because you you
double down on likeness that person's
just like me all right um uh
additionally you can reference my my
Rihanna video on some of the things they
did for their offer but in this offer
having birthday and anniversary offers
is just it's wonderful reason why to
extend personalized offers to people
that will increase their specific
urgency but the thing is is that you
know that every month you've got one
12th of people who returning a certain
age and so you've got basically one
sixth because you've hit anniversaries
and birthdays every single month that
are getting a special offer and so if
you do that on a regular basis it's like
every month you get this kind of lift to
one sixth of your audience that's
getting a special offer specific to them
all right and so um here are a couple
actionable takeaways that I think you
can take away from their site to convert
more out traffic so number one is
website optimization so if you haven't
tested your page load speed um just do
it and then most tools will tell you
some of the things that images that need
to be compressed um so that you can
decrease file size and ultimately load
faster now this may not sound
interesting but for every 1 second saved
you get I think I think Neil Patel had
this uh he he's already studied this one
but I think it's something in the
neighborhood of like a 2 and a half or
something like that perc increase in
conversion per second and so sometimes
I've seen some of your pages you have 9
seconds 13 seconds of load time it's
like if you can get that down to like 3
seconds You've Got 2 plus per time 10 uh
in terms of improvement on uh conversion
right if you click and it's like
changing a channel on a television
you're going to convert more people now
um the next one is using side by-side
comparisons I'm surprised that they
aren't really hitting on this heavily
so they talk about it really heavily in
their advertising but they're not
showing um what other people are doing
comparatively and so this is one where
like Progressive kind of pioneered this
in the insurance industry where they
were showing what other uh plans cover
and prices Associated and I think if you
are the underdog then it's okay to do
that if you're the top dog you don't
show anybody else's but if you're M if
you're if you're making a budget as your
primary sales point then using side by
side makes sense because they can see
the Delta one of the other things here
that I think is probably worth
mentioning is hidden fees one of the one
of the big concerns with budget
providers like budget Airlines is that
they will charge you for each piece of
luggage they'll charge you for drinks
they'll charge you for everything it's
like are they going to charge me for
anything else and I think being explicit
about that somewhere would probably
increase conversion so if I'm them I
would be looking at the same plus good
stuff away from bad stuff and if you you
don't work with us so selling the don't
you're going to keep having bad stuff
and keep not having good stuff and
that's where having the justos of the
other providers could prove for very
good fodder for ongoing emails and so
like one email would just be more good
stuff next email would be less bad stuff
next email would be uh if you don't do
this you'll keep having bad stuff if you
don't do this you'll keep not having
good stuff and then each of the good
stuff and bad stuff you have three
vectors that you can look at across all
four of those which is risk speed and
ease and so showing the visual of the
step-by-step process of what it takes to
sign up that could de it could drisk
someone's concern about how easy it is
from a speed perspective I would
probably hit on more points of like well
how quickly can I get act activated
right like could I be using my phone
within a few minutes if I could I would
want to know that so I would talk about
speed um from a risk perspective they do
they are um they do have commitments
Associated and so I'd want to know what
are my cancellation policies and what
does cancelling look like so believe it
or not if you actually just show someone
how to cancel before they buy sometimes
they're just more likely to buy because
they're like oh I understand how I can
get out of this it reverses the risk of
the purchase now the big obvious one is
that price is another thing that they do
but I wouldn't say that's an area of
opportunity I think they already hit
their price pretty hard if you like
these types of real business breakdowns
I had a small business owner who is a
stylist who flew out to Vegas to have
her business broken down and improved
it's the video of the year that I got
the highest amount of Praise from
business owners 4 who said this was the
best video they had had and so I want
everyone to watch it because it's really
good so go check it out